(creepy music)
- [Joanna] I think people
now are more afraid
of death than they've ever been
because they're not familiar with it.
Because it seems like this exotic other.
If every single person who has ever lived
has died, it can't be that bad, right?
I can't imagine how one wouldn't be
fascinated by death.
My name is Joanna Ebenstein.
I'm the Creative Director and co-founder
of the Morbid Anatomy Museum.
The name Morbid Anatomy seems to suggest
to a lot of people something more like
the American Morbidity Museum
in American Horror Story.
And so, people will come in and be like,
"Where are the dead babies?"
And we're like,
"No, we don't have dead babies here."
(upbeat music)
There's two parts in the museum:
There's the temporary
exhibition which is always
borrowed from different
private collectors.
And there's this room we're in which is
the Morbid Anatomy Library.
I think a lot of people
who like this project
are people who had to
choose at a certain point
between art and science.
I always wanted to be a scientist
and I wanted to be an artist.
So I'm always interested and drawn to
artifacts from time
periods before those things
were divided up.
These ideas that death and beauty,
art and science, cute and horrific,
have to be separate.
When I was a kid I loved animals.
And I loved live animals, I loved my cat.
But also I loved looking at animals
at the Natural History Museum that were
in a jar in formaldehyde.
My college friends would call me morbid
because I liked to pick up roadkill
and preserve the skins.
I never stopped doing it.
But I was cognizant of
the fact that people
thought I was a freak.
Really through starting the museum,
that's when I really discovered there were
so many more people like me
than I ever suspected.
(light music)